hey Vsauce Michael here about 6% of
everything you say and read and write is
the the is the most used word in the
English language about one out of every
16 words we encounter on a daily basis
is the the top 20 most common English
words in order are the of and to a in is
I that it for you was with on as have
but be they that's a fun fact a piece of
trivia but it's also more you see
whether the most commonly used words are
ranked across an entire language or in
just one book or article almost every
time a bizarre pattern emerges the
second most used word will appear about
half as often as the most used the third
one third is often the fourth one fourth
as often the fifth one fifth is often
the sixth 1/6 as often and so on all the
way down seriously for some reason the
amount of times a word is used is just
proportional to one over its rank word
frequency and ranking on a log-log graph
follow a nice straight line a power-law
this phenomenon is called zips law and
it doesn't only apply to english it also
applies to other languages like well all
of them even ancient languages we
haven't been able to translate yet and
here's the thing we have no idea why
it's surprising that something as
complex as reality should be conveyed by
something as creative as language in
such a predictable way how predictable
we'll watch this according to word count
dot org which ranks words as found in
the british national corpus sauce is the
five thousand five hundred and fifty
fifth most common English word now here
is a list of how many times every word
on Wikipedia and in the entire Gutenberg
corpus of tens of thousands of public
domain books shows up the most used word
the shows up about 181 million times
knowing these two things we can estimate
that the word sauce should appear about
30 thousand times on Wikipedia and
Gutenberg combined and it pretty much
does what gives the world is chaotic
things are distributed in myriads of
ways not just power laws and language is
personal intentional idiosyncratic what
about the world and ourselves could
cause such complex activities and
behaviors to follow such a basic rule we
literally don't know more than a century
of research has yet to close the case
moreover Zips law doesn't just
mysteriously describe word use it's also
found in city populations solar flare
intensities protein sequences and immune
receptors the amount of traffic websites
get earthquake magnitudes the number of
times academic papers are cited last
names the firing patterns of neural
networks ingredients used in cookbooks
the number of phone calls people receive
the diameter of moon craters the number
of people that die in wars the
popularity of opening chess moves even
the rate at which we forget there are
plenty of theories about why language is
zippy but no firm conclusions and this
video doesn't contain a definite
explanation either sorry I know that's a
bummer since we appear to like knowing
more than mystery but that said we also
asked more than we answer so let's dive
in to zips ramifications some related
patterns some possible explanations and
the depth of the mystery itself
zip slaw was popularized by George Zipp
a linguist at Harvard University it is a
discrete form of the continuous Pareto
distribution from which we get the
Pareto principle because so many
real-world processes behave this way
the Pareto principle tells us that as a
rule of thumb it's worth assuming that
20% of the causes are responsible for
80% of the outcome like in language
where the most frequently used eighteen
percent of words account for over 80% of
word occurrences in 1896 vilfredo pareto
showed that approximately 80% of the
land in Italy was owned by just 20% of
the population it is said that he later
noticed in his garden 20% of his pea
pods contained 80% of the Peas
he and other researchers looked at other
datasets and found that this 8020
imbalance comes up a lot in the world
the richest 20% of humans have 80 2.7
percent of the world's income in the
u.s. 20% of patients use 80 percent of
healthcare resources in 2002 Microsoft
reported that 80% of the errors and
crashes in Windows and Office are caused
by 20% of the bugs detected a common
rule of thumb in the business world
states that 20 percent of your customers
are responsible for 80% of your profits
and 80 percent of the complaints you
receive will come from 20% of your
customers a book titled the 8020
principle even says that in a home or
office 20 percent of the carpet receives
80 percent of the where oh and as Woody
Allen famously said 80 percent of
success is just showing up
the Pareto principle is everywhere which
is good by focusing on just 20% of
what's wrong
you could often expect to solve 80% of
the problems a variety of different
unrelated factors cause this to be true
from case to case but if we can get to
the bottom of what causes some of them
maybe we'll find that one or more of
those mechanisms is responsible for zips
law in language George Zipp himself
thought languages interesting ranked
frequency distribution was a consequence
of the principle of least effort the
tendency for life and things to follow
the path of least resistance Ziff
believed it drove much of human behavior
and hypothesized that as language
developed in our species speakers
naturally preferred drawing from as few
words as possible to get their thoughts
out there it was easier but in order to
understand what was being said
listeners preferred larger vocabularies
that gave more specificity so that they
had to do less work the compromise
between listening and speaking
zip felt led to the current state of
language a few words are used often and
many many many words are used rarely
recent papers have suggested that having
a few short often used predictable words
helps dissipate information load density
on listeners spacing out important vocab
so that the information rate is more
constant
this makes sense and much has been
learned by applying the least effort
principle to other behaviors but later
researchers argued that for language the
explanation was even more simple just a
few years after zips seminal paper
benoit mandelbrot showed that there may
be nothing mysterious about zips law at
all because even if you just randomly
type on a keyboard you will produce
words distributed according to zips law
it's a pretty cool point and this is why
it happens there are exponentially more
different long words than short words
for instance the English alphabet can be
used to make 26 one letter words but 26
squared two letter words also in random
typing whenever the spacebar is pressed
a word terminates since there's always a
certain chance that the spacebar will be
pressed longer stretches of time before
it happens are exponentially less likely
than shorter ones the combination of
these Exponential's is pretty zippy for
example if all 26 letters and the
spacebar are equally likely to be typed
after a letter is typed and a word has
begun the probability that the next
input will be a space thus creating a
one letter word is just one in 27 and
sure enough if you randomly generate
characters or hire a proverbial typing
monkey about one out of every 27 or
three point seven percent of the stuff
between spaces will be single letters
two letter words appear when after
beginning a word any character but the
space bar is hit a 26 and 27 chance and
then the space bar a three letter word
is the probability of a letter another
letter and then a space if we divide by
the number of unique words of each
length there can be we get the frequency
of occurrence expected for any
particular word given its length for
example the letter V will make up about
point 1 42 percent
of random typing the word Vsauce point
zero zero zero zero zero zero zero zero
nine nine three percent longer words are
less likely but watch this let's spread
these frequencies out according to the
ranks they'd take up on a most often
used list there are 26 possible 1 letter
words so each of the top 26 ranked words
are expected to occur about this often
the next 676 ranks will be taken up by
two letter words that show up about this
often if we extend each frequency
according to how many members it has we
get zip subsequent researchers have
detailed how changing up the initial
conditions can smooth the steps out our
mysterious distribution has been created
out of nothing but the inevitabilities
of math so maybe there is no mystery
maybe words are just the result of
humans randomly segmenting the
observable world and the mental world
into labels and zips law describes what
naturally happens when you do that case
closed
and as always thanks for what wait a
minute actual language is very different
from random typing communication is
deterministic to a certain extent
utterances and topics arrive based on
what was said before and the vocabulary
we have to work with certainly isn't the
result of purely random naming for
example the monkey typing model can't
explain why even the names of the
elements the planets end the days of the
week are used in language according to
zips law sets like these are constrained
by the natural world and they're not the
result of us randomly segmenting the
world into labels
furthermore when given a list of novel
words words they've never heard or used
before like when prompted to write a
story about alien creatures with strange
names people will naturally tend to use
the name of one alien twice as often as
another three times as often as another
zips law appears to be built into our
brains perhaps there is something about
the way thoughts and topics of
discussion a band flow that contributes
to zips law another way zippy and
distributions occur is via processes
that change according to how they've
previously operated these are called
preferential attachment processes they
occur when something money views
attention variation friends jobs
anything really is given out according
to how much is already possessed to go
back to the carpet example if most
people walk from the living room to the
kitchen across a certain path furniture
will be placed elsewhere making that
path even more popular the more views a
video or image or post has the more
likely it is to get recommended
automatically or make the news for
having so many views both of which give
it more views it's like a snowball
rolling down a snowy hill the more snow
it accumulates the bigger its surface
area becomes for collecting more and the
faster it grows there doesn't have to be
a deliberate choice driving a
preferential attachment process it can
happen naturally try this take a bunch
of paper clips and grab any two at
random link them together and then throw
them back in the pile now repeat over
and over again if you grab paper clips
that are already part of a chain link
them anyway more often than not after a
while you will have a distribution that
looks as if Ian's a small number of
chains contain a disproportionate amount
of the total paper clip count this is
simply because the longer a chain gets
the greater proportion of the whole it
contains which gives it a better chance
of being picked up in the future and
consequently made even longer the rich
get richer the big get bigger the
popular get popular it's just math
perhaps languages Ziff mystery is if not
caused by at least strengthened by
preffer
Rachele attachment once a word is used
it's more likely to be used against soon
critical points may play a role as well
writing and conversation often stick to
a topic until a critical point is
reached and the subject is changed and
the vocabulary shifts processes like
these are known to result in power laws
so in the end it seems tenable that all
these mechanisms might collude to make
Zips law the most natural way for
language to be perhaps some of our
vocabulary and grammar was developed
randomly according to Mandelbrot's
theory and the natural way conversation
and discussion follow preferential
attachment and criticality coupled with
the principle of least effort when
speaking and listening are all
responsible for the relationship between
word rank and frequency it's a shame
that the answer isn't simpler but it's
fascinating because of the consequences
it has on what communication is made of
roughly speaking and this is
mind-blowing nearly half of any book
conversation or article will be nothing
but the same 50 to 100 words and nearly
the other half will be words that appear
in that selection only once that's not
so surprising when you consider the fact
that one word accounts for six percent
of what we say the top 25 most used
words make up about 1/3 of everything we
say and the top 100 about half seriously
I mean whether it's all the words in wet
hot American summer or all the words in
Plato's Complete Works or in the
complete works of Edgar Allen Poe or the
Bible itself only about 100 words are
used for nearly half of everything
written or said in Alice's Adventures in
Wonderland 44 percent and in Tom Sawyer
forty-nine point eight percent of the
unique words used appear only
once in the book a word that is used
only once in a given selection of words
is called a hey pax legume anon hey pax
lag Amina are vitally important to
understanding languages if a word has
only been found once in the entire known
collection of an ancient language it can
be very difficult to figure out what it
means now there is no corpus of
everything ever said or written in
English but there are very very large
collections and it's fun to find hey pax
lagaa Mona in them for instance and this
probably won't be the case after I
mention it but the word quiz Aish ously
is in the Oxford English Dictionary but
appears nowhere on Wikipedia or in the
gutenberg corpus or in the british
national corpus or the american national
corpus but it does appear when searched
in just one result on Google fittingly
in a book titled elder speak that lists
it as a rare word quiz Aish asleep by
the way means in a mocking manner as in
the parodist rattled off quiz Asia Slee
hey Vsauce Michael here but who is
Michael and how much does he weigh
it's a little sad that quiz Asia Slee
has been used so infrequently it's a fun
word but that's the way things go in a
zip ian's system some things get all the
love some get little most of what you
experience on a day to day basis is
forgotten forgettable the dictionary of
obscure sorrows as it often does has a
word for this
Oh Lika the awareness of how few days
are memorable I've been alive for almost
11,000 days but I couldn't tell you
something about each one of them I mean
not even close most of what we do and
see and think and say and hear and feel
is forgotten at a rate quite similar to
zip slaw which makes sense if a number
of factors naturally selected for
thinking and talking about the world
with tools in a zip Ian way it makes
sense we'd remember it that way to some
things really well most things hardly at
all but it bums me out sometimes because
it means that so much is forgotten even
things that at the time you thought you
could never forget my locker number
senior year it's combination the jokes I
liked when I saw a comedian on stage the
names of people I saw every day 10 years
ago so many memories are gone when I
look at all the books I've read and
realize that I can't remember every
detail from them it's a little
disappointing
I mean why even bother if the Pareto
principle dictates that my zippy in mind
will consciously remember pretty much
only the titles and a few basic
reactions years later Ralph Waldo
Emerson makes me feel better he once
said I cannot remember the books I've
read any more than the meals I have
eaten
even so they have made me and as always
thanks for watching
[Music]